[موسيقى]
حرب اوكرانيا التي تابى ان تضع اوزارها
وهذا ليل الفيف غير الهادئ وتحت القصف
الهجوم الروسي بمسيارات على المقاطعه
الواقعه الغربي البلاد تسبب في مقتل شخص
على الاقل ونشوا بحريق كبير في مستودع
التهمت النيران مساحه تزيد عن تسعه الاف
متر مربع استنادا لروايه حاكم الاداره
العسكريه الاقليميه اعلان الروسي اخر عن
ضربه في جبهه بخموت المشتعله والتي تتضارب
فيها الانباء بين طرفي الحرب بثت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه صورا قالت انها لجثث جنود
اوكرانيين سقطوا في بلده كليشيفا نافيه
سيطره قوتك على هذه المنطقه روايه
اوكرانيا تفيد بالتصدق قواتها لمحاولات
روسيه شن هجمات على محور بخموت شرقي
البلاد بهدف استعاده المواقع التي خسرتها
في الفتره الاخيره
اختلاف الروايات حد التناقض وكثرتها في
عده مناطق واستحاله التاكد من كل حدث من
مصدر مستقل يجعل الصوره ضبابيه بشان من
يتقدم ومن يتاخر واين ومتى في هذا الصراع
المعقد بكل تفاصيله لا يعرفها الحديث وزير
الدفاع الامريكي
للهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد مصدره معلومات
دقيقه ام لرفع المعنويات وحشد الهمم علما
ان النقاشات بين الدول الغربيه حليفه كياف
خلف الابواب المغلقه بشان هذا الهجوم الذي
بدا في يونيو الماضي تنتهي بتحفظات
وانتقادات في افتتاح اجتماع مجموعات
الاتصال بقاعده رمشتاين في المانيا بشره
اوستن الاوكرانيين بقرب تسليم الدبابات
الموعوده
يسرني ان اعلن ان دبابات التي تعهدت
الولايات المتحده بمد كييف بها ستدخل
الاراضي الاوكرانيه قريبا لقد عززت مجموعه
الاتصال هذه دعمها لاوكرانيا من خلال
تزويدها بانظمه دفاع جويه
كان الرئيس بايدن مطلع العمل شاري وعد
كيان باحدى وثلاثين دبابه تسليمها الذي
سيبدا خلال الايام المقبله قد يستغرق بضعه
اسابيع سترسل الدبابات مع ذخائر
باليورانيوم المنظم عيار 120 مليمتر وهي
قادره على اختراق الاليات المصفحه والدروع
هذا النوع من الذخيره مسار جدل كبير اذ
تسبب حسب دراسات مشاكل صحيه مثل السرطان
والتشوهات خلقيه في المناطق التي استخدمت
فيها ماذا ستقدم ايضا واشنطن وعن ماذا
ستتراجع في سبيل هذه الحرب المكلفه
والمرهقه فبعد ان استبعد مسؤ ول الدفاع في
السابق تسليم الدبابات كونها غير مناسبه
للقوات الاوكرانيه بسبب تعقيدها حدث العكس
وها هي في طريقها اليهم
وحده الطريق الى السلام في هذا الصراع غير
معبد ووعر حتى الان